the restaurants full but now she's
front-of-house sweet is using every
trick in the book to boost business two
hours in and the food's not going out
quick enough treaters faith in Brian is
dwindling fast so we're in the lift
phase one for Brian three years of
living the Connery coma is a hard habit
to break
he's beginning to lose it and sherita's
constant interruptions aren't exactly
helping come on Brian
don't lose it now you know what else on
this table I need to see what's on it I
need whatever else is there they are
getting restless I'll tell you what the
problem you can't expect the food to
just jump on your planner we don't play
that sore after yeah since it's a good
14 20 minutes to make sure that you know
you don't kill enough okay as that pig
feet go on cuz it needs to go on now cuz
it takes the time yeah I have three
minute you in here we're losing money
[ __ ] you now so what do you think of
that meat load thank you didn't I tell
you didn't I tell you I thought because
you got a really good start you were
slightly nervous being down there
because you are sort of not spying on
them but coming up yeah educated yeah
yeah you lost it Brian a little bit
envious
yeah he sits on the interesting though
yeah Judah has to understand it's gonna
take three or four minutes longer
because I'm cooking from raw and the
benefit is the customer but I think this
guy yeah with the help of AD and get
faster yeah much much faster I mean how
would you sum up you're in the dining
room and it felt good because I'm
telling you for three-and-a-half years
being it was the first Saturday night
uh-huh that I have spent downstairs
they've seen you in a that's the fish
they want to see when they come to see
mama downstairs I'm gonna be cracking
the whip a lot harder they show business
course you know and that term I was
thinking yeah you know I got a crack it
let's go okay thank you good thank you
guys let me go down here saying cuz I
got a few more desserts to sell yeah